well as michael said it is a holiday and
so a shot of jameson is in order and mr
tyonne towing the slab and the boogie
down here but here is marcus simeone
what a season he has put together 35
homers and 82 rbis
[Music]
there's one deep drive to left field get
up get out of here and gone stay hot
marcus
number 36 and just like that the blue
jays have a lead
there is nothing like making a statement
when you come into a huge series like
the blue jays are right now in new york
and you make a statement in the first
inning and who better to do that than
marcus simeon guerrero had three hits
yesterday all three singles going the
opposite way tie on deals
and a curveball is popped up down the
right field line starting to travel well
judges at the wall and he can't get it
it's gone
the youngest player in franchise history
vladimir guerrero jr with 40 home runs
the blue jays have gone back to back and
it's tuned up being toronto in the first
today it'll be yin jin ryu trying to get
the blue jays off to a good start here
in new york
another spring of this that's
183 strikeouts for a gal two up two down
here in the first
same piss gets a ground ball oh has it
scooped over at first by vladi three up
three down no problem for ryu and the
first abujas with an early two-nothing
lead here in new york
here's anthony rizzo he gets the first
pitch fastball and oscar makes a running
catch right on the warning track a line
drive but the oscar was set got a good
jump and makes a nice running catch to
up to down quickly here in a second
there's a change up that he hits
to the shortstop oh is there another
three up three down ending six in a row
retired by ryu and the blue jays have a
two-nothing lead as we head to the third
in bronx
the 2-1
and the [ __ ] lofted to shallow center
gardner on the run dives to make the
catch he throws to second to complete
the double play
though gardner made the catch springer
took off the third and he was standing
there on the double play so the double
play what a crazy game a double play
goes 8-4
deals 0-1
swung on a fly ball to center
gardner is there to make the catch
nearest the 0-1
swung on and line to right judge back
edge of the track makes the catch
and they're a 2 away
that one's popped up
so he had a six pitch
fifth inning
and a seven pitch
sixth inning
gia o'shella digs in
and lines one to left field is a base
hit
that's the yankees third hit
and a good start to their sixth inning
so geo lines a base it now the top of
the order lemay you gallo and judge
flickering its shadow behind the on deck
hitter joey gallo 2-2 reaches after
change-up rolls are right up the middle
the shet with two hands feet simeon for
one high throw to first bloody holds the
bag to get the double play
a ball in the middle of a diamond sucked
up by buchet
he laid it right over the back for
marcus simeon
who fires to vladi
taylor made 6-4-3
the 2-2 curveball strike three called
a beautiful hook snapped off by hyunjin
ryu he gets gala on strikes for the
third time today and ryu faces the
minimum with six shutout innings
werner goes swelling and miss throw to
second
and he got back he overslipped the bag
but he did get back so hernandez with
the stolen base and a strike out of
dickerson
one down for lourdes gorilla jr
swings at the first pitch and he lines
it into left center field a base hit
hernandez turns the corner he's coming
in to score on an rbi base hit for
lourdes gorilla jr three-nothing blue
jays
toronto capitalizing on the lead-off
walk here in the seventh inning
and lourdes gorilla jr stays hot there's
kevin smith third baseman number nine
batter another fly ball left field
though tess gallo again
another battle with the sun and he wins
that one
but boy he's taking some punches
so the boujee has to make a pitching
change with judge stanton and rizzo the
scheduled banners for new york it'll be
trevor richards here in the seventh
great change-up what a comeback he was
down 3-0 he comes all the way back and
strikes out judge
came right back with a changeup and
strikes him out
popped him up
middle of the diamond vladi at first
base calls forward it moves to his right
and richards gets out of a couple of
strikeouts and a pop-up yankees leave a
base runner we'll go to the eighth
this will be the 51st game for litki not
much to complain about with this guy
phil count to springer
he found that one off his leg and that
one got him flush it's the last thing he
needs another issue with a leg we've got
that brace on his
left knee
yeah and that's been bothering him
that's the problem that you have when
you've got to deal with a lefty that
throws a lot of cutters on the inside
part of the blade
3-2 and you can see he was still hurting
up there
and he goes down on strikes the last
thing they need is for springer to be
hurt again he can hardly walk without
well he is limping for sure
grounded to urshela
and he gets pachette
for the final out here in the eighth no
runs you hit one man left bottom of the
eighth coming up yankees down by three
as the blue jays begin there at bat but
to oscar hernandez one oh hernandez
swings and he drives the ball down the
left field line hooking into the corner
and gone
tay oscar hernandez with a frozen rope
right up the left field line and it's
four nothing blue jays
he hit it hard enough it left the bat
fast enough and he kept it true enough
into the front row above the fence in
left field hernandez with number 25.
marcus with the
[Applause]
the sixth grand slam for the blue jays
this season and they've busted